today's episode is brought to you by
liquid death
i'm happy to announce that the return of
the rat tour will be picking up some
steam
february 2nd in jacksonville florida at
the florida theater february 3rd in st
petersburg florida
february 5th orlando florida february
25th rockford illinois
february 26
chicago illinois
and
friday may 6 over there in tulsa
oklahoma
saturday may 7th in los angeles
california
what else that's it man i'm excited
about it rockford illinois home of the
rockford peaches
we are members of the all-american
league i'll be excited to be over there
seeing everybody and doing it right
those are on sale uh today on thursday
until 10 p.m uh with the code rat king
you can go to theovon.com
tour for tickets and uh thank you guys
so much for supporting my career i'm
excited to get over there and bring the
new tour to you let's go
today's guest is returning to the show
uh he is an attorney an
environmentalist uh his new book the
real anthony fauci
is on amazon new york times and usa
today
uh number one bestseller uh he's my
friend i'm happy to spend time with him
always mr robert kennedy jr
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
yeah thanks for coming in man
happy to be here thanks for having me
again yeah it's really good to see you
uh the book man i've i've read as much
as i can and listen to as much as i can
so far just because it's a lot of
information
you know especially um
information probably isn't probably my
top strong suit but i think it's getting
better but um
what was like the research process like
for putting together a book like this
um
a lot of it was just like reading my
emails because i have a list if
with
almost 300 doctors and ph mds and phd
scientists on it
and so a lot of the um
a lot of the kind of the current science
wait if there's a new study that comes
out and lands her gem or any of the
4 000 journals that are out there i see
it almost immediately okay
and then i see it discussed
um by people who are highly critical and
know how to
read science critically
so i can see them arguing with each
other and criticizing the study and
finding its weaknesses and all that kind
of stuff and it allows me to kind of
make better evaluations of it but you
know i've known fouchy for a long time
okay
and i um
and i also have a peculiar insight
into the phenomena of agency capture and
that is the dynamic by which
environmental agencies and public health
agencies
become sock puppets of the industries
that are supposed to regulate it happens
with every agency so i have everything
it happens with all of them whether it's
the sec or the fda
or you know
ncc
yeah any of the three letter agencies
ultimately
over time the industry figures out how
to infiltrate them how to control the
senators and the congressmen that write
their budgets
how to get control of that agency
because it's so
important for their profit ambitions
right
and so
i probably brought over 500 lawsuits as
an environmental lawyer
mainly against polluters who are
discharging into the environment into
the air water whatever
but probably during the 38 years that i
was doing that probably 20 of my
lawsuits were against the epa or the
state environmental agencies for
issuing these kind of sweetheart illegal
permits because they get compromised
also you're saying because they get
compromised so i was used to that
dynamic right
kind of hard to navigate yeah of seeing
the agency that's supposed to be my
friend but it's actually my enemy you
know on these
environmental issues i was accustomed to
that but
that dynamic is particularly acute it's
really on steroids
in public health agencies because there
are these unprecedented entanglements
financial entanglements for example
fda gets
45 of its annual budget from
pharmaceutical companies oh they're
really you know there's really no it's
kind of a seamless
subsidiary of the industry and it's
really
it's agency capture on steroids so the
fda is funded mostly by pharmaceutical
companies about half of their money
comes from pharmaceutical companies and
that's because
we passed a law in the
um in the 90s
at a la actually in the in the early
2000s that allows it's called fast track
approval so the drug companies were
complaining that you know these drugs
take 10 years to get approved
and a lot of the particularly the
republicans on capitol hill who want the
agencies to be more industry friendly
they said there ought to be a process
where the where the industry can come in
and pay
to get a very very quick approval
and so now that seems dirty business it
is dirty business it's there's a kind of
a rational reason for it as the agency
said
we simply don't have enough
personnel
to quickly process these applications
so congress said
okay well we're going to get the
industry to give you the money to hire
the people to process it
but really what happens is the agency is
now being paid to do its job by the
industry and they become partners and
they're no longer
a regulatory agency they're really you
know their their regulatory mission gets
subsumed by these commercial and
mercantile you know
and like you're saying it foreign in
every aspect yeah and you know once
advertising and everything comes into
anything it gets uh it gets a little bit
polluted yeah and with the covid you
know
crisis
um it's
from the beginning it really the
response to the public health agencies
was not a public health response it was
a mercantile response it was how do we
get money to these vaccine companies it
wasn't how do we save lives and
particularly with our country and that's
why you know our country
we have the worst track records we have
a highest with what well
we have 4.2 percent of the world's
population but we had 20 of the coveted
deaths and that's all on anthony fauci
right the mismanagement that took place
he basically got rid of early treatment
so 80 of the people who went to hospital
should never have gone to a hospital
yeah it felt like that this is a regular
person it felt like something strange
here that all these people just hooked
up to this thing they're being hooked up
to machines
if you went to let's say if you went to
your doctor yeah
and you and you have maybe a headache or
you lost your sense of taste
it's an early symptom it's not
debilitating
and he gives you a pcr test
and the pcr test say you've covered
what does that doctor now do
here's what he does under tony fausch's
regimen he tells you go home
you're so sick that your lips turn blue
because you can't breathe
and go to the hospital and we're going
to put you on a ventilator which is
going to probably kill you right and
we're going to give you rem deserve
error which is going to probably kill
you but did they know in the beginning
that the that they because it felt like
um
it felt like they didn't know like no
one knew how
severe it was so at first maybe they
don't know what to do the doctors the
thing is
at the very beginning you can say that
but by april they knew that hydroxycoin
worked right and they actually knew much
earlier because in 2005 nih
did studies on coronavirus that showed
hydroxycoin obliterated it and then in
2013 2014 fouchy funded studies on
mirrors and sars which are coronaviruses
that again show that hydroxychloroquine
completely destroyed it okay so what was
the difference this time whenever they
did church what they the problem was and
see the chinese the pandemic only lasted
for two months why because they were
doing early treatment they were also
doing a lot of others really
aggressively locking people up
who had governed but they were treating
them
they were treating them with chloroquine
which is hydroxychloroquine plus they
were treating with antibiotics
anti-inflammatories
on anticoagulants steroids monoclonal
antibodies and vitamins well all the
things that we know worked and we we
weren't treating we weren't doing a lot
of you we're not doing any early
treatment and the reason for that is
this
the
aochi was focused on the vaccines was 98
billion dollar enterprise
and
he had to get for that enterprise to
work he had to get them emergency use
authorization because otherwise
the pandemic would be over by the time
they got their real you know permits
their licenses
you had to get them emergency use
authorization it is illegal
under federal law
to give emergency use authorization for
any vaccine
if there is an existing drug
that has been approved for any purpose
that is demonstrated effective against
the target disease right and how drug
school green you said had been had been
demonstrated effective it was and now
there's 285 peer-reviewed studies that
show that 80 of the people
who enter the hospital should not have
gone if they had gone hydroxychloroquine
or iron early they would never not have
gone to the hospital and they would not
have died
but if tony thought she recognized that
the entire vaccine enterprise would have
collapsed because he could not have
given that it would have been illegal
for him to give
emergency use authorization to any
vaccines we had to kill those drugs up
front who
who controls the emergency use
authorization
he
really he does
because he was in charge of the
government response and he's the one who
decided to move this back he's the one
who decided we're not going to do early
treatment
we're going to wait
make sure everybody has to go to the
hospital
and we're going to tell everybody lock
yourself up
put the whole country under house at
rest
and um and wait there until we get our
vaccines ready don't do anything else
that helps you and you never knew he
never did what what you would want a
america's doctor to do
which is to give a speech to the
american public and say
you need to take vitamin d you need to
think you need to lose some weight right
because the it's the obese people who
are going gonna die you need to get
outside and get exercise
you need to build your immune system
when he was at
eighty percent of the people who died
from covet were vitamin d deficient wow
we know that vitamin d completely
it destroys scoping
there's a study that came out three
weeks ago that said if
people
anybody who had 50
uh
um
50 what they call us nanoliters per
decade
of
vitamin d in their blood
did not get covered
and it said theoretic hypothetically
you could have
completely eliminated covent as by
making sure people had adequate vitamin
d yeah
we never heard that sunshine
and people have known that for years we
know this ink works against common yeah
it did seem interesting there was no
like okay these are things you can do to
help prevent yourself from covid
everything was just wait until you got
the vaccine put a mask on that's a good
point social distance
ask yourself in the house well even also
the weird thing of if people got it that
they sent them back home like
just go home and be in a room at your
house that was weird to me it's like
well if this is so deadly then why is my
friend brendan you just told him to go
home and be in a separate room than his
family who's in this but not to like be
in different buildings
but and that's the thing where they're
sending sick people to nursing homes was
it going to kill everybody in the
nursing home yeah
it's the inverse of everything that you
that
we knew that you're supposed to do
it's the inverse of everything that
chinese did the chinese
if you were sick they grabbed you they
brought you to a hospital and they gave
you early treatment they would not let
you go um when americans were told to do
go home do you get so sick that you're
going to die oh yeah then go to the
hospital well every one of those
hospital visits was a super spreader
event because that person now is
infecting they're putting maximum viral
loads out into the environment
they're infecting their whole family
they're they're infecting the uber
driver the door dash they're infecting
the people in the hospital the people in
the ambulance and
dry cleaning
it's not what you wouldn't want to do if
you wanted to stop the pandemic right
so then my question this there would be
like um do you feel like but did fauci
know this did you do so like with the
book are you saying that they knew this
in advance
like they knew that hydroxychloroquine
would help so they they kind of allege
is that they shut down
a lot of like the i think it's i don't
know if it's over the counter or under
counter hydroxyl chloroquine like
there's places where it was it was
allowed over the canada france many
other countries
the
hydroxyl argument is available or was
available over the counter and at the
beginning of january as soon as they
heard coronavirus was circulating the ae
they those countries reclassified it as
a poison but you can only get it private
prescription no but did you have
anything to do with the countries that
didn't do that
the african countries where hydroxycork
when it's taken every sunday it's called
sunday sunday in africa because
everybody takes it on saturdays from
malaria prevention
those countries
those countries the death rate per
million population was two one two three
four five
in our country twenty two hundred per
million population died from covenant
and i have in tanzania less than one or
twenty two hundred so we had twenty two
hundred
times the rate of death
as the tanzanians had we had a thousand
times the rate of death as the chinese
did
you look at the african countries and
nobody's dying
and one of the reasons for that is
probably that they're all on ivermectin
and hydroxycholera do you think they
could be under reporting over there too
because there's less like information
yes that could be happening but we're
also over reporting here yeah
and but everybody agrees that
those countries have done better than us
right we don't you know you make a good
point we don't know the there's been
such sloppy haphazard reporting that we
really don't know what happened in our
country i mean even cdc says
that only six percent of the americans
who died from covet had only covered at
the average number of comorbidities in
the other people who died and 94 percent
was uh 3.8 comorbidities potentially
fatal co-morbidity so
we don't know whether they died with
covet or whether they died after
do you believe that they knew before
like did they know
like that the virus was coming or did
was this a like a surprise thing that
happened and then they
i say they but like the
you know i guess who am i even trying to
say like because i know the book kind of
the book talks about how
like big pharma basically pharmaceutical
companies um and like
like fancy rich people basically i guess
or powerful people kind of like
cannibalized the hydroxychloroquine
thing i don't know if cannibalize is the
word but like tried to sync it like
there was a test that they did like
european test studies something where
they used too much
um yeah to show the trials that it
didn't work yes
so what happened like how'd they get us
to believe that hydroxyl working didn't
work they what they did was bill gates
funded these three studies uh the
solidarity
each group some studies with thousands
of people
solidarity study recovery study and
remap study
and in those studies
they studied hydroxychloroquine
supposedly but what they really did
hydroxychloroquine only works if you
give it to people in the first 10 days
after infections or first symptoms okay
if you could give it to him once in
their hospital the disease has changed
at that point and it's a not very
effective shifter so they only gave it
to people who were hospitalized in order
to discredit it
and then they gave people three or four
or five times the normal dose they were
giving them lethal doses
and they were killing people and in fact
the researchers that did the studies in
brazil killed i think 29 out of 41
people who are in the study they're
elderly people oh they also they're
currently
they're currently being prosecuted for
homicide really
by the brazilian prosecutors but that's
how they were able to persuade the world
that hydroxychlorine aquin is dangerous
they were giving them dose of
hydroxychloroquine that they knew
were going to kill people
so but then wouldn't they be brought up
on charges wouldn't they be like um
in brazil they are being brought up on
charges so just to cut this just the
testing facility but not it wouldn't go
up to gates in fact it wouldn't go up
higher than that well if you
you know if you read in my book there's
an interview with one of the researchers
who was being funded by gates
and he's talking to a very famous
scientist called tess laurie and this is
the first chapter of the book she's a
researcher for the who she's a contract
scientist who does clinical trials for
the who and she was doing a meta review
which is a review of all the literature
and hydroxychloroquine and
ivormectin and
she was talking to a scientist who was
clearly on the take
and
she was saying to him we are looking at
the same studies
and you know this drug works so why are
you not telling the truth about it and
he's saying
i'm being pressured not to three days
before he issued his study gates donated
40 million dollars to his university
and he and it was gates uh
organization that was funding that study
and clearly gates
had a strong interest in killing
ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine
gates has invested in all these you know
look aids had invested billions and
billions of dollars in these vaccines
right in the car hydroxychloroquine and
i've met and worked
his enterprise would have been
spoiled yeah because the the hql or
whatever is that hql is that what they
call it hcq h
hydroxychloroquine yeah
hydroxychloroquine
it's like 10 bucks a dose or something
right it's not super expensive it's like
put together
oh
it's 30 cents a pill i got screwed then
i freaking paid up yeah the batch i
bought is a little spicier than that but
um
but so but so
but why would why would they do it it
was just them they and rem deserve air
is three thousand dollars right
and then of course the vaccines which
don't work
you know are making even more than that
i mean not more per doze but they're
making you know huge amounts of money
well let's stick in the space right now
where it's like uh so the
so they they tried to create articles
and stuff that
just and trials that dissuaded people
from using the hydroxychloroquine
there's a lot of about that in the bow
yeah um
and the information
because i would see stuff like you would
see stuff come up sometimes on social
media like this and you know oh what if
this works you know where people are
having effect effectiveness with this
and it would always be shut down right
it would be like um
either just lambasted by just the the
masses uh or it would be like um
uh scrapped from platforms like scrubbed
out of platforms right like you saw this
sometimes with information
how do they how would the people who are
creating this this plan
basically
uh to get the this vaccine through how
would they also be able to get people to
then halt any information that's coming
out that's contradictory because there's
just so many people that can put out
information you know yeah and you know
what i would say is we ought to have
free speech
is that you know if they're if
somebody's telling lie on the social
media
if somebody's um saying something that
is not true
that the remedy for that is not shutting
them down right the remedy that is more
speech is being able to show people
totally different it's okay
you know let
ideas triumph in the marketplace yeah
and not somebody be in charge of
shutting them down but very early on in
the pandemic
the media and the social the media is
funded by pharma and they have been
doing censorship on pharmaceutical
issues for decades
but the social media really for the
first time started acting as sensors and
you know many of these companies are
deeply tied in with the pharmaceutical
industry
google has three vaccine companies
um google makes one of those companies
it owns three vaccine companies well
google's uh
parent company is called verily or
alphabet
and at companies so
google has sister companies yeah
that are making vaccines flu vaccines
they make women are always up to
something yeah
um zuckerberg has about a billion
dollars invested in vaccines of you know
from his private his foundation so a lot
of the big money that are tied into
these uh that are tied into um tech
companies they also own pharmaceutical
companies
and they're tie they have deals with
pharmaceutical companies like
google has a 70 i think a 76 um million
dollar deal with glaxosmithkline
and they and you know they the um they
have all kinds of deals with the
pharmaceutical company to mine
information health information from
their
databases and so they're really
kind of part of the pharmaceutical
industry right
and why is it that that industry has
gotten so
how did we let this industry the
pharmaceutical business gets so big i
mean
i see it all the time like in recovery
places and stuff like that people just
i see some people that i feel like are
alcoholics and i see some people that
are victims of just insane medications
it's like you see people whose lives
have just been wrecked by pills that
they couldn't combat if they had a
million weapons you know the power of
some of the oxycodones and all of that
stuff um
how did we let these pharmaceutical
companies start to net like control the
way um how do we let them like
bypass whatever
government we had looking out for us or
something and and
how do we let this happen does that make
sense
yeah okay good one of the issues is
pharmaceutical advertising what they
call direct to consumer advertising so
there's only two countries in the world
that allow pharmaceutical companies to
advertise to the consumers
other countries companies say no you
can't do advertising if you want a drug
go to your doctor and he will tell you
in our country in 1997 we changed the
rule
so that allow pharmaceutical companies
to advertise on tv oh so
in 2017 i went to the um
to the uh president of fox news
i called roger ailes oh yeah i remember
a very famous guy and he's dead huh he
yeah he died but when i was 19 years old
i spent three months
with him in a tent in east africa
and i had this weird relationship
because he was like for me you know
politically he was like darth vader
but we had a personal friendship and we
both enjoyed each other and he was
very very kind to me you know i was
doing environmental stuff and fox news
doesn't like the environment too much
but he would make sure that his
that the
shows on fox news would always let me on
to at least talk about my side of this
story
and
i went to him i think around 2018 i went
to him with a movie that we had just
made about mercury and vaccines
and he had a child who had and that he
suspects it was vaccine injured
he was very sympathetic to
this movie and he saw it he watched it
he believed it but he said i cannot let
you go onto my network to talk about it
and he said if any of my
hosts
allowed you onto their show i would have
to fire them
and if i didn't i would hear from rupert
meaning rupert murdoch within 10 minutes
and he said to me
during non-election years we get fox
news for its evening news that's up to
70 percent of its revenues
from
that from pharmaceutical companies oh
and if you look and he said that's the
banker typically there's 22 ads on a on
an evening news show
and typically about 17 of those are
pharmaceutical ads so those companies
are not just
using that as a platform to promote
their products they are dictating
content on that new show and that's why
anderson cooper makes 12 million dollars
a year
a 10 million dollars of that
is coming from pfizer
typically yeah so
he knows who he's working for and that's
why you know he's always promoting flu
shots and vaccines and medications and
all this and telling you you need to
lock down you need to do what the pharma
tells you to do
and meanwhile they locked us all down
they put us you know they induced this
this condition called stockholm syndrome
where americans are living in terror
they become grateful to their captors
and they believe that the only way to
return to normal and to you know to
survive is to is total compliance to the
you know to their captors and that's
what we're kind of dealing with now in
our country why aren't there more people
who try to stay or who are trying to
speak out against this i what's what's
interesting so much about about the book
so far that i've read is um just how
many it resonates with like these really
like fears and kind of questions i've
had about this whole thing like a lot of
it hasn't passed like some of the smell
tests for me ironically just i've just
never felt comfortable with some of the
ways some of this has been handled like
i've witnessed friends like i've had six
friends that overdosed in the past two
years yeah and they're dead you and i
was a lot of people and yeah and it just
in her dead like and you know like they
didn't die of cover they died because
they couldn't get into there are no
recovery rooms there's no meetings
there's no connection of humanity you
know it's like people they don't know
that somebody cares about them because
they're not seeing other humans every
day they're locked away um
because of the mass and stuff it just
seems like how would there not be more
of a just re
revolt coming out of
more people uh to
question this it feels like because
because of fear
disables the part of your brain that
does critical
thinking and if you can you know this is
a
this is a lesson it's one of the
alchemies of tyranny if you if you are
if you want a totalitarian regime
and you know gerring said this at um
at nuremberg he said it's an easy thing
for any government to manipulate its
people you just have to get them scared
tell them there's an enemy and what
better enemy than a germ that can get
into everybody's house and kill them and
that you're the only one compliant if
only doing what you're told
is going to allow you know you to
survive
and one of the you know one of the
things that i don't know if you've seen
this but
in
december in october of 2019
there was there was a pandemic
simulation called event 201 and i write
about it in the last chapter of the book
an event 201 was a group of people who
simulated a coronavirus pandemic now
remember this is in october of 2019 in
new york city the pierre hotel
and there are a lot of big shots there
and we now know
according to the national security
agency
that coven 19 began circulating on
september 12th damn it's oh in wuhan
that's a rough month for us across the
board historically right now well
september 12th um what happened is the
the and the satellite
and if there was chatter all over the
internet coming out of wuhan
of people talking about symptoms that
were very much and also cures from those
symptoms
the hospital parking lot the aerial
photographs show that
it was full
there were three people in the lab who
ended up going to the hospital with
coveted symptoms the
the chinese government that night at
midnight
went into the lab they
removed 22 000 samples of coronavirus
that were public in the lab and they've
never been seen again
he also took all of the public-facing
web pages and they removed
documents and papers about gain of
function and we know this is a fact it's
a fact this is what the national
security agency is okay they believe
that september 12th was the day that it
actually began circulating okay
a month later
you have in new york city he's bill
gates
hosting a coronavirus pandemic
simulation
at that his co-host
is avril haynes the deputy director of
the cia
what is the cia doing at a public health
forum they don't do public health they
do coup d'etat
and now abrahams is the top spot in
america she is the and she is the one
who hid the torture
the torture tapes from abu ghraib
you know during the cia scandal so that
she now is the head of the national
security agency tops in the country
she's also in charge of the coronavirus
response
at the simulation you have april haynes
you have people from all the social
media companies
you have people from the pharmaceutical
companies mainly johnson and johnson the
biggest one
they do and you have another guy a
peculiar guy george gayo
who's the head of the chinese
cdc oh man he's not sneaky anybody so
george gale must have known yeah that
this was circulating at that point
by the way any of your listeners who
does not believe what i'm saying can go
and look up event 201 it's still on
youtube and this was before the
it was after it started circulating but
none of us knew about it okay anyway
before the this is after the nsa had
said that this had occurred the nsa now
says looking back this is hurting it
occurs
until around january 3rd so then there
was a big get together of some of then
they're all together they're planning
what oh here's how we're going to hand a
look around a virus pandemic if it
happens
was fountain there no vouching was not
there but there were people from his
agency there so
and the interesting thing is
there was no discussion of public health
they weren't saying how do we gonna get
repurposed medications how are we gonna
link
11 million doctors frontline physicians
around the world on a communication grid
so that we can quickly figure out what's
working you know what's working in
bangladesh what's working in argentina
what are the best protocols what are the
best repurposed medications that seem
effective right like what's already
working against this type of thing that
we could ask people to get prepared and
get on now to help themselves well
nobody even when it starts
if a ground of irs pandemic starts
you want to be able to talk to all the
doctors who are treating it around the
world
and find out because there may be a guy
in argentina which there was dr cavallo
who's got good intel who uh who was
giving i from acting to people
he gave it to 700 frontline healthcare
workers and he gave a placebo to 458
and if the 700 who got it not one of
them got covered of the 400 who didn't
got it 53 got covered so he knew that
very early on
but that wasn't being communicated and
if you were fouchy and really wanted to
do a public health response
you'd be connecting all these doctors
and mining what is the best intelligence
what's the best way to treat people how
do we avoid hospitalizations how do we
avoid tests
and you're saying they were just
connecting more of the business side of
it they weren't the only thing they were
doing was they were saying how do we use
a pandemic
to clamp down totalitarian controls to
essentially
execute a coup d'etat against democracy
how do we get rid of the bill of rights
oh do you think that they brought that
up in this meeting listen
i'm not saying nobody can should believe
me on anything they should go and do the
research themselves and you go to event
201 and here's what you'll see
the fourth simulation that day it took
breaks there was a total of four the
fourth one is the longest one that whole
simulation is
how do you get the social media
companies
to censor
dissent
and how specifically
do you get them to not talk about the
fact that this was a lab-generated virus
they the george geo says that and this
is what they're talking about for two
hours
this isn't october what was their fear
that if people thought it was a
lab-generated virus
and they would start pointing at chinese
blaming not only the chinese but blaming
public health officials who were all
funding you know those studies in wuhan
oh i see it was not just value is
funding the gain of function studies it
was
the um usaid which is a cia conduit it
was detracted defense threat uh reaction
reduction agency
and it was a panic on through darpa and
barda so they were giving hundreds of
millions of dollars
to develop coronavirus superbugs that
could cause pandemics
and they were doing it with the chinese
so you're saying that you you believe
that the whole thing was even planned
ahead that no i i'm not saying it was
planned i'm saying and this is not
controversial we know this was happening
as well documented they were publishing
about it okay so the republicans they
were doing this research there they were
doing research to develop weapons right
and they were saying we're doing the
research
because the same research that we need
to do to develop weapons we can also
develop vaccines it was illegal for them
to develop bio weapons i see because so
they were saying we're doing bio weapons
research but it's clear they were doing
well it's weird to create a murderer to
test a prison is that's a weird thing
it's like why would you you know train
murderers just to test out a prison
facility you built but is it the same
people paying to to do the trials that
were that own the
vaccine
the thing is tony
it was an anthrax attack oh damn
on our country in 2001 oh yeah
i remember so
and in
1972 or 69 we signed
a treaty that said you can't develop
weapons anymore
and so nobody touched them the cia was
secretly doing it but
the pentagon was not
in 2001 after the anthrax attacks and
the anthrax attacks
were blamed on sana hussain
the fbi's investigation showed that the
anthrax had not come from said um it had
gone from one of three
u.s army laboratories
somebody in the military
had something to do in the u.s military
with those anthrax attacks okay what
happened is after the anthrax attacks
they use that as an excuse to start
developing bio weapons again
ah the pentagon did not want to do it
within the pentagon because they said
because there was a loophole in the
treaty that said
you can't develop bio weapons but you
can do dual use research dual use means
research that is bioweapons research but
it also is useful for developing
vaccines okay
so they began
funneling 1.6 billion a year to tony
fauci
to do
weapons research because he
would be the pentagon didn't want it to
win the pentagon because they said
nobody's going to believe that we're
doing vaccine research i see it would
just be too erroneous yeah so they
farmed it out of algae and they gave him
a 68 race and where was he at the w.h.o
oh he was an and i i i did he ever
worked for the wh oh yeah he worked for
50 years at nih
that year his salary went up 68
from the pentagon
and today he's the highest paid person
in the federal government that's insane
to me yeah but his 70 of his budget
is for doing this bio weapons research
that's why he had to keep doing it even
when obama ordered him to stop in 2014.
that's when he moved it offshore to wu
on
and they all moved to uh so obama tried
to shut him down
what happened is in 2014 four of his
bugs escaped or three of his
escape from different labs
and 300 scientists petitioned obama and
said you got to shut down fauci because
he's doing this research he's going to
release a bug that is going to cause a
global pandemic
obama ordered him to stop
he illegally continued to do the worst
of these studies at the university of
north carolina with a scientist called
ralph barrack
and then but he began funneling huge
amounts of money laundering it through
this you know this
sketchy
a con man called peter desak was a
zoologist who was working for the cia
and he began and the cia and arpa began
funding all of this money 100 million
dollars through days act to distribute
to chinese military scientists at the
lab okay
to do the studies there to do the
studies and the purpose of doing the
studies is they say it's for vaccines
but it was really this chinese were
really open say they said we're doing
bio weapons i didn't care yeah chinese
or whatever the americans were all
saying this is vaccine research the
chinese were saying this is awesome
you'll flick a cigarette right into it
one of the really telling studies that
how she funded at the university of
north carolina
was a study that
called a scene to develop what they
called a seamless legation process
which was a way of hiding the human
tampering so what they were doing is
they were taking ground of viruses
and infected bats
they were removing the spike protein
that could only affect bats
and they were building
inserting a spiked protein that was
designed to infect humans they they used
the way they tested this they had
humanized mice with human lungs
they had bred mice with human lungs and
they were testing these microbes on
those mice and if the mice got sick they
knew humans would get sick because they
had an agent
right human lungs
and how do you even get a human lung and
a mouse
with a little tiny tweezers yeah
they bred them but so they're over there
so
what what
how she funded
not only was he funding them to switch
up the spike protein that only infected
bats and switch it for ones that would
only infect humans
but then he was developing processes for
hiding the evidence of human tampering
that's the last thing that you would
want to do if you cared about public
health right which allows you know
malevolent people
to conceal the fact that this virus was
human-made wow and so it had nothing to
do with vaccines it was about and he
funded it ralph barrack who he gave he
gave 57
grants to this one scientist
he called it barrett calls it his notes
in process so it's a process where you
can
alter it
and then nobody can see it
he then taught that process to the
chinese military scientists she shingley
she was a bad lady
and he taught her how to do it and then
for two years the chinese went dark
and then we had covered my team
so do you think that that they that it
was created on purpose then and then it
got out like was the do you think that
that was created on purpose and then it
because they knew that they would be
able to because
i don't know if it's fouchy but they
knew that they would be able to then use
the
well here's the thing in my book i don't
any of that kind of speculation right
what i show is the facts
and then people i think if you read the
facts you can make up your own mind
there's a lot of facts in there i mean
look and there's so many sided sources i
honestly felt like you were like a guy
like we were playing the game clue and
you're like in the room you're like
you're like i'm in the library with the
candlestick you know it's exactly kind
of what it really felt like the energy
coming out of it there's so much
information on the revelations in the
book okay
algae gave 2.2 million dollars billion
billion dollars
to this little cambridge company called
moderna
and gates it took h was pouring money
into him to develop an mrna
vaccine the head of that company is a
french guy called stephen bonzell
the company that built the wuan lab
was a french company called biomero
part of their contract was to develop
what they call a negative air system
that
keeps
airflow from flowing outward it's a very
sophisticated and you need it in these
bsl4 labs these biosecurity four labs at
the most unprotected lab protective labs
and the world secure labs in the world
and it's where they you need those labs
to do these studies
you need a negative airflow system
because
some of these bugs are gonna get into
the air right and they could go out got
to keep it indoors
so he was contracted
bureau of the french company
was contracted to build the
negative airflow system but they didn't
do it
the head of that company was stephen
banzil
he then goes
without building that system so he is a
good idea
that these bugs are going to escape yeah
it's a dark
and in march of 2019 so this is five
months before the
you know the escape he goes back he's
been denied a patent for his mrna
vaccine
he goes back and reapplies to the us
patent office for the patent and in the
patent application he says there is an
urgency that you give this patent to me
and processes immediately
because of the chance
of an accidental or deliberate release
of a laboratory generated
virus that
this vaccine is the only thing that will
cure it wouldn't the research and know
that he has the ability to
oh we you know we have his patent
application and it says that in there
wow
damn oh man it's a lot to digest
i'm very impressed that you made an
effort at least to read it yeah i think
i'm maybe i think i'm maybe almost i
could possibly be halfway through um
there's parts where you talk about uh
and this was something that i heard
spoken about a lot that there were uh
that doctors or facilities got more
money if there was a coveted death
than if it was a regular death yeah is
that true or not yes okay and you know
the hospital systems
were heavily incentivized to classify
um every death they could as a governor
so even people who came in with car
accidents we know this from a lot of
whistleblowers
were if they could get a positive pcr
test they were given rem deserve they
would put oftentimes on intubation
because they got 39 000
for doing those procedures on they did
and if it was a covet death and they
coded it coveted
even if the person didn't die of covet
he just had coped in his blood
they got a lot more money so that was
it's one of the things that really
confuses the data that we have and you
know we don't have any good data and
that's one of the problems but
let me let me just talk let's talk for a
second about the fizer study because
everybody's taking the vaccine is the
only one that has approval okay
the pfizer vaccine study the trial from
the beginning we knew it was going to be
rushed
tony fauci promised us it's going to be
completely transparent and we're going
to get four year studies so we're going
to know
you need long studies when you decide
anything dude it takes four years to get
to college you've got to be four years
to be uh you know a
banker yeah i mean because there's a lot
of injuries that come from medications
but particularly from vaccines
yet of long diagnostic horizons or they
have no long incubation periods so you
won't see them first in six months
they're cancers autoimmune diseases
seizures neurodevelopmental disease of
course you will not see a four in a six
month period and also
what they call antibody dependent
enhancement which coronavirus are
notorious about the if you get a vaccine
in all the previous
experiments with coronavirus vaccines
the people who got the vaccine and the
animals that got vaccinated actually got
sicker
when the coronavirus came back around
when they were exposed to wild
coronavirus you won't know that until
you have a long term study
oh what did he do
six months into this study
he declared it over who did fauci yeah
he unblinded it which means he told all
the people about grew up in the blessed
hebrew oh yeah it's like that and he
gave the vaccine to everybody in the
placebo group so he erased the placebo
group which means we have
no way ever
have long-term
ideas about oh based on that study
there's no way to know long term because
it was unblinded and everybody in the
placebo group was given the fact that
it's true yes
then they took that's crazy let me let
me tell you the rest of this
and they took the data from that six
months this sounds like clown paces
are shooting into people man i mean it's
just that sounds crazy
and they took the data for that six
months and they brought it to fda fda
gave them a license
what did that data show here's what
there's one graph that's called that s4
you can see it it's in my book in the
first chapter and this
this graph
is the most critical graph because it is
the graph for all cause mortality in
other words
when you look at the vaccine group and
you look at the placebo group
where who which of those groups had more
people alive at the end of the study and
more people dead at the end of the study
and here's what it says
there were roughly 22 000 people in the
vaccine group
22 000 people in the placebo group
at the end of six months this is what
their own data show
one person in the vaccine group of those
22 000 died from covid
in the placebo group
two people died from covet
that allowed pfizer to tell fda and the
american public
the vaccine is 100 effective because two
is a hundred percent of one yeah
oh most americans when they hear the
vaccine is 100 effective yeah
i think if i get the vaccine i'm 100 not
going to die of covid well why wouldn't
more information come out like other
people be screaming that this seems like
kind of a ridiculous thing why does it
seem like because the press is all
sensitive i mean what's
when you've er the show
you're going to get killed oh we're
scared
we're scared
off the air i don't think we could be
you might have to take it down but let
me just finish what happened so
so what are really most americans think
i 100 won't die let's say if i get the
vaccine but that's not what it means
what it means is they have to give 22
000 vaccines
to save one life from copen
now if you're going to give those 22 000
vaccines
you better make sure
that the vaccine is not going to kill
even one person because if it does right
it's now canceled the entire benefits
well here's what their data show and
again this is table s4
i urge people to go to it
in the vaccine group 20 people died of
22 000 over six months
in the placebo group only 14 people died
so what that suggests
is that if you take the vaccine
you're 48 more likely to die over the
next six months than if you don't
how are they dying
mainly heart attacks so in the vaccine
group five people died of heart attacks
in the placebo group only one what that
means if you get the vaccine
you have a 500 greater chance of getting
a heart attack and if you don't based on
that time period of that study yeah and
the study is probably a crap study that
doesn't really mean anything because
there were too few people in it
robert malone who invented the mrna
vaccine told me this week he said ad
study means nothing they need it they
can't do a study with twenty two
thousand people it sounds like a lot
they need four hundred thousand they're
going to give this to 350 million people
yeah
he needed four hundred thousand in the
study to make any real predictions so
these predictions probably aren't real
but they're stuck with them because
they're the ones who said we're only
going to put 22 000 people in this study
and what they show what their study
shows
is that
for every life that they say from kovid
they killed four people from heart
attacks wow we got a question that came
in actually right here from a guy uh
for you bobby that's right this is live
this is not live
none of this is live and this question
isn't live this is because i want to
make sure you have an option of not
playing this podcast video no i don't i
think we're okay
yeah i mean we
you know i'm generally curious and i
think i'm worried about your career
that's why well the good i feel like i
own my own career until
like i don't need a hollywood career you
know but it's definitely i worry about
like my career of like i guess maybe
like youtube canceling us or people
saying that we can't do this anymore you
know that's the scary part is this on
youtube yeah this will be on youtube
so but our last one stayed up
okay well let's make a bet i'll bet you
five
bucks happening a lot let's make it 10.
we got a good question right here from
somebody that came in
hey theo hey mr kennedy
um i'm here with a question for you all
um
so i got the covet vaccine i needed to
to in order to keep my job i live in the
city of philadelphia
and uh is uh
they're pretty gung-ho about making sure
everybody's vaccinated but anyway i got
it and i ended up having uh
myocarditis like developing heart pain
and a serious reaction as a result of it
um
and
i don't really know what to do i don't
have good health insurance or anything
like that i can't really uh spend a lot
of money to get to the bottom of it
um and all we hear in the news is like
oh it's so rare for people to have these
effects from it but like
we don't hear much at all about what to
do if you are one of the people that
ended up having one of these uh side
effects from the vaccine so
i was wondering if mr kennedy here has
any advice on what to do if you do get
that uh that pumped up uh ticker
and uh how to help it how to help
deflate that
um baby or
i mean that person you know i mean that
guy could also have a stricken a strong
carbonara sauce from a cousin or
something that freaking amped his kicker
up but um but i think that's that's
really serious disease
i mean really serious 50 percent of the
people who are diagnosed
it myocarditis
either die
or require a heart transplant within
five years so a lot of these you know
the cdc is telling people well you know
these are mainly mild case there's no
such thing as a muscle case you you know
what that means is they discharge you
from the hospital
and you go home and you have uh six
months of bed rest and a lot the people
who are most susceptible to it are
athletes
um there's a very very strong hong kong
study that came out a couple of weeks
ago that says that
for young people
one in every 2700 is getting myocarditis
that is huge particularly because
we don't know if it's vaccine-related no
from the vaccine that are reporting
myocarditis from the vaccine kids don't
have heart attacks kids don't have
strokes yeah they're myocarditis these
athletes you're watching every day
literally two a day now
athletes are collapsing on playing
fields as for myocarditis and it's from
the vaccines and there's no question
about that and that's what this study
shows
1 in 2 700 people are getting
myocarditis
are they for for kids
there are two studies out for you know
they're now going to give this to
children and the younger you are the
more likely you are to get myocarditis
from the vaccine jesus what the lancet
study showed
is that they were not able to find a
single healthy child in america that
died from covet
there's a there are children who died
but the people very obese or
a lot of comorbidities
they couldn't find any healthy children
who died and the germany just released a
study of its database and very very
similar
they found the death rate in healthy
children was three per million okay so
three per million and under five zero
literally zero not one kid found it who
is who
died from covet
if the death rate is three per million
but one in every 2700 people
are getting myocarditis
that means you have a hundred times
greater chance
for every one person
that they're saving from covet
there are a hundred people getting
myocarditis what about this do
couldn't it
but but you you're not an ant you're not
are you you're not anti you're an
anti-vaccination you're here oh so the
vaccination is
does it help people
or do we just not know the long term
what's going to happen i don't think
anybody
first of all the vaccine
what tony fouchy said the vaccine was
going to do in bill gates
was that it was going to prevent
transmission and prevent hospitalization
and prevent you from getting the disease
and it doesn't do any of those it does
not prevent transmission of vaccinated
person according to the best science we
have now
is he and tony fauci has said this and i
will if you need it i'll send you the
recording and you can put it in here
okay
um he even says that you're equally
likely
to transmit the disease if you were
vaccinated or unvaccinated so there's
yeah it feels hella confusing i mean
people are still have to wear masks you
don't have to wear mass it's this
and there's no
you know people originally were saying
that you're more likely to get a severe
disease but when you look at the one
database
that seems most reliable
is the british the uk databases and what
those databases are showing is that the
people who get go who get the vaccine
are more likely to be hospitalized
that's what their data is showing okay
those data may be skewed in some way
they may not be um completely reliable
but it is the best database in the world
and it's showing it it's not showing
that the vaccine will avoid
hospitalization or death we're not
seeing that but why wouldn't like uh
fouchy and gates and some of these big
pocketed dogs have uh have a say so in
that kind of study coming out like why
wouldn't they mean of the nhs data
that's raw data that is data that you
know it for many many years
the british have been publishing their
mortality and morbidity data directly
from the hospital directly from the
corners directly from the health agency
so anybody can look at that and when you
look at that and you you can compare on
that
a hospitalized people who were
vaccinated to the hospitalized people
who are unvaccinated
and what you will see
is that the
that the front you you're actually more
likely to end up in a hospital on by
that data okay
if you got the vaccine then if you did
not right and that's still early in data
too we still need a long it's still
early and we don't you know and also
there may be the data could be
data could be skewed and let me tell you
how that people can understand
um you could argue is
that the people who were early
vaccinated
were less likely to get coped early
and when the vaccine wears off
now there's more of that subset who are
getting sick and getting hospitalized
and people who are unvaccinated
i'm by percentage so
so we don't know the answer to that
i doubt that that's really what's
happening but you know we don't know
how did um have have there been doctors
that have come out and supported your
book as well or is there like i mean
there's a list of hundreds of doctors i
know there's tons of data from doctors
in there yeah but if you look at the
beginning of the book it's there are a
couple of pages of just very very tiny
type of all the doctors who are
you know who are opposing the tony fauci
narrative
um and do you feel like
has the book been
uh have you been supported by any
mainstream media alice do you feel like
it's growing in some senses do you feel
like the book has been completely
boycotted by the media
but the sales have been amazing we've
been you know at the top of the best
seller list
i mean the new york times won't put us
number one even though even if you were
number one well we are number one
because we know how many for example you
know i think in the first week we sold
93 000 copies will smith uh sold 85 000
and he's the top i'm number seven and i
sold more of my books than all the other
ones
but they still put me seven because i
just think they don't you know they do
not want to give me the publicity being
number one
wall street journal put me number one
the usa today which is the hardest one
because they combine all the books in
the world including fiction and
non-fiction together so that's the
hardest one to be number one and number
one there
publishers weekly number one amazon
number one number two or number three
day after day after day
number one for the weeks
yeah i mean i've had a lot of people
since you were coming on who certainly
reached out to me and uh
applauded the fact that we were just
going to talk about it um we've got
another good question that came in here
let's get uh let's get to one of these
what's up theo this is adam um hello mr
kennedy
uh congratulations your books number
three on amazon right now i just checked
it
i had a question in your book in the
back you had a list of arbitrary decrees
and i thought it was very interesting i
was going to get your opinion on
new york's recent decree from de blasio
about vaccination across the whole city
even for private businesses thanks
we actually you know um
well
it
i mean i've already made the case that i
if a vaccine is not preventing
transmission
what is the justification right for
mandating that somebody take it yeah you
know i mean we listen we sign the nurse
i agree that's i've long that's my big
question why do people half
it doesn't seem deadly enough for people
to have but even if it's deadly i mean
it's my choice uh nobody can make me
take medicine for my own good right
and you know there's a there's a
argument
if me i think the vaccine is going to
prevent other people from getting the
vaccine there's no argument that the
state has the right to force me to take
the vaccine but
there's no that argument doesn't exist
because if you get the vaccine you're
equally likely to transmit the disease
and you know by the way
we signed the nuremberg protocol we a
lot of americans died so that we could
sign the treaty at the end of the war
and the nuremberg protocol says we will
never again
no country whose signature
will ever can
force
individuals to take an experimental
product with uh without their informed
consent
no form of commercial coercion
is
is legal
and the all of the vaccines that are
available in this country now
are experimental they're all eua there's
not one vaccine that is now available in
the united states that's been approved
the pfizer vaccine one version of it the
commonality vaccine is approved but it's
not available in the united states
oh de blasio is ordering people to
participate in a medical experiment
and that's you know is not something we
do in america yeah
why has it become that how did we get
from the point where it feels like these
days like the government is more like uh
facebook and cnn and twitter these are
the judge and the jury of everything as
opposed to like um
you know human beings and i mean it's
still human beings but
as opposed to like an actual government
as opposed to like um it almost seems
like it's a the government's like a
shell company now for like um
for tech you know like i always say like
tech is the new fossil fuel that's what
i feel like a little bit it's like this
it has such a power over it's like how
did we kind of let that happen was it
just money that did it
yeah i mean am i crazy no i think that's
right and
you know what we've seen this year is
really pretty extraordinary to you it's
the
it is the abolition of all of our bill
of rights so they started out with with
by controlling those tech companies they
were able to effectively get rid of
freedom of speech and freedom of
expression
madison and adams and jefferson
we put
freedom of speech into the first
amendment
because all of the other rights are
dependent on it if a government
can
control can stop criticism or dissent
it has a license to commit any kind of
atrocities so as soon as they got rid of
freedom of speech
they went after the other half of the
first amendment which is freedom of
religion and
worship it closed all the churches in
our country for a year
with no public hearing no debate no you
know science shown
they then went after property rights
they controlled it they shut down a
million businesses
with no process no just compensation
then they went after jury trials you
cannot sue
the sixth and seventh amendment say this
no american shall be denied the right of
a trial of a jury of his before a jury
of his peers for any case or controversy
exceeding 25 dollars in value
well
that's all it says there's no pandemic
exception right today jury trials are
going in our country foreign if a
vaccine company or pharmaceutical
company injures you you cannot so no
matter how egregious you're really
no matter how negligent they were no
matter how reckless they are you can
assume so if 20 million people die
15 years from now from the vaccine there
can't be a class-action suit no
wow
you cannot see them there's no discovery
there's no way we got to make a vaccine
bro yeah so i need to make a vaccine
baby we need to
the vaccine will not give you immunity
but it gives the company that made it
immunity
from liability that's crazy that's
what's happening and then
you know
the the prohibitions against warrantless
searches and seizures are gone in there
you know they're doing you have to show
your vaccine cards and you know they
have private medical information to
people there's track and trace
surveillance well it's cost me my value
it's starting to cost me and this is
just my feeling and i'm obviously a very
sensitive person but it's costing me a
lot of what i feel like my whole
purposes of being human are
um and so it starts to make me feel like
there's no real value in me being human
and so i think if you are already
predisposed to ideas like that in your
head and kind of negative self-thought
and idealism
nihilism
nihilism yeah it was just i might have
misdone it
but i don't say n-i-h-i-l-i-s-m yeah
yeah
nihilism i didn't know that was it but
yeah it's like if i'm already
predisposed then that's where i see a
lot of my friends who are perishing you
know it's like uh because
the
cdc says
that one out of every four people under
20 contemplated suicides this year
suicide rates are off the chart the drug
overdose the alcoholism the child of
child abuse is down why
oh because a child 90 of child abuse was
reported by the schools
and the schools are closed those kids
are now home
with their abusers
and uh really but yeah it's just there's
no way to yeah there's no way to report
it oh and you know all of these other
metrics of of what you know of people's
ideas of community their connections to
their family their connection to
community have been obliterated this
year and no there was no attention
yeah
he did he didn't say
that yeah you know what there are
studies out there what happens when you
unemploy people and there is a famous
study from 1982
it says and that when we had half the
population so double all these numbers
that every point in unemployment caused
37 000 excess deaths
heart attacks stress suicides etc
3 300 x as imprisonments
4 000 x as
admissions to mental hospitals
so not employment and they just went and
it was 20 unemployment overnight yeah
armor we had a round not a rabbit we had
like a mount like a long mouse when i
was growing up and if we took his wheel
out of there literally like a week later
you could see how defunct he was you
know yeah just because he just had
nothing to do
um
uh
why but here's a question i have so if
if if farmer was like being able to
manage all of this with power and money
and influence right
you know or manage at least like the
information that was getting out
and suppressing other information
because they
they
advertised enough or were the biggest
supporter of different
outlets
why weren't other businesses why weren't
it like
businesses like hilton or hardy's
dickies uh
you know carnival cruise lines how
weren't there other big businesses that
were lobbying like in the other way like
against this like this is
you know other companies with big money
why weren't they able to lobby and say
this is ridiculous
yeah i think you know what i'm saying
like like companies that would it's
really that is a really good question
but i i think one of the things they did
for those companies is they bought them
all off
you know they paid the airlines and they
paid the cruise lines and um
you know they um
you know they were they printed money
they're you know they're billing the
next 10 generations and they're they're
keeping the corporations rich and i
think you know a lot of those businesses
didn't want to put their heads up over
the parapet yeah
anybody who sticks their head up and
says you know this is wrong they're uh
you know what's going to come down on
them is uh
makes it so that they're too too scared
so your family in the past could have
been a victim of espionage
yeah do you think that that is something
that fuels your
your
i don't know if it motivates me i think
i mean really i stumbled into this issue
because he's you know i was suing
um
cement kilns and culverting power plants
for putting mercury and fish there was
and you're the environmentalist the
environment was on the outside and now
they're going they've come inside of us
and there was a group of women who had
children who had intellectual
disabilities and they believed that
their kids talking about this
had um that were vaccine injured and
they basically forced me to read a bunch
of scientific studies and when i read
them i got pissed off
and that brought me down the rabbit hole
but um
you know i've written a couple of books
and many articles about um
my
about what happened to my family and my
family had a six-year battle with the
cia
i'm very very familiar with um you know
with all of that uh intrigue and and the
involvement in the intelligence agencies
my uncle's death and in my father's
death
so because i'm attuned to that i also am
i have an open mind about you know an
ability kind of to to look and say why
are they involved with
public health right
these agency
c-i-a was involved in 73 coup d'etats
between 1947 and 2000.
one-third of the countries in the world
they've never done public health yeah
you know why are they now deeply
involved in public health and that event
201.
that's interesting as i show up my book
was not one off
they were doing that drill year after
year after year and each one of them the
cia was involved and they were
simulating pandemics again and again and
again beginning in 2000
anthrax smallpox coronavirus flew
and every one of them the cia was
involved why is that
yeah i mean it's so it's that's the
thing it's like there's a lot of things
that i re get to certain
get the ends of certain chapters into
certain paragraphs and it's like man why
is that
yeah i think that's the number one
takeaway that i haven't and reading as
much of this as i have so far like
man why is that
um
yeah why is this chef
over here teaching rollerblading you
know what i'm saying like why is this
business over here with this business um
do you worry about like uh
do you feel like give any lawsuit
worries with this book or no
it wasn't no yeah i mean truth is
defense the libel and everything in the
book is true yeah i mean maybe somebody
will find a mistake but i have 2200
footnotes in there with references so
every statement factual statement in
that book
i have a reference for a source for that
and and we have a qr code that allows
what's never been done before in a book
that allows anybody who reads this book
to go to the references and view them on
their cell phone oh wow
do you think we've become too lazy as a
population have we already become too
like addicted to this technology and
addicted
to
just because we've definitely something
has happened to the human right um
yeah and the problem is i think we're
cooked man listen the the ambition of
every totalitarian regime in human
history has been complete control of the
population
they've never been able to do that
before you can always escape to the
hills you can read books secretly you
can have a radio and you're you know and
frank um had secret books she had it you
know they had a radio in the basement
all this
today you can't do that today there's
nowhere to hide bill gates said it is 65
000 satellites are going to be able to
surveil every square foot of the earth
24 hours a day
they have track and track surveillance
everywhere now
they have um in china they've already
deployed software
i can read guilt on the human face they
claim oh it's pre crime if you feel
guilty about it you know they can scan a
football stadium and pick out the people
who look guilty we're perverts too oh
yeah
you know what they're doing is these
vaccine passports
that's going to completely change our
relationship with our rights because
right now you have a whole bunch of
rights right you can go to the bowling
alley you can go out to a sports game
you can hang out with whoever you want
to hang out if you can get on a plane
and travel
you can educate educated you can do all
these things those are rights
you get that vaccine passport that
becomes a privilege
it is conditional
on your compliance so if the vaccine
passport says you got to get four
boosters a year and you didn't do it
you now can't get in the ball game you
can't get on the airplane the rights are
now conditional they used to be
unconditional now they're conditional
and here's where we're going
we're going to digitize currency so
you're you know social credit will be on
that vaccine passport your credit scores
will be on that vaccine passport
and
in europe this is one of the things when
i went over there you know two weeks ago
and gave speeches about about the
passports which they're now imposing
the passports are not being issued by
the health departments the health
ministries they're being issued by the
financial ministry
why is that
yeah because we're going to digitize
currency
they're going to be able to look at
every transaction they're going to get
rid of currency which we're already
doing it's already hard to find coins oh
yeah you can't even give somebody a
dollar they don't even know what to do
that's where we're going we're going to
digitalize currency they're going to be
able to
track every single transaction that you
have
they're going to be able to tax it the
financial institutions are going to be
able to make money on the friction of
every transaction but they can also do
what they call programmable money
which is if you are for example if you
don't get your vaccine of your
disobedient
and they say to you okay you can't leave
your house and you can only shop in
grocery stores within one mile of your
house
your
currency will now only work in those
grocery stores it will not work in a gas
station wow so if you don't have a
passport then you can't even buy certain
places
or you can't travel you can't if they
you know you
if
if you live in
pasadena
it can say
your your
money will only work in pasadena it
won't work you know it won't let you to
drive to brentwood
they can completely control every
movement that you have you you can't buy
gas you can't buy anything except what
they want you to buy and that level of
control is you know i think really
destructive and that's where we're going
so what's going on are people just going
to lose like just tyrants going to take
over and just attack the samsung
building or like what's going to happen
you know well i i think
how do you reply this is happening in
every country in the
world the one place where
people are
standing up is um
ironically it's in the red states in
america
yeah
i was in louisiana yesterday and i gave
a speech a presentation to
um the you know the legislature there
and they voted against
the you know the mandates to children
and it was democrats and republicans
voting against it was a bipartisan vote
um but i think in those a lot of the
states you go to that state there's no
mass same with florida same with texas
people i live in tennessee some and
there's no man and it's been fine like
that's the thing i just don't understand
what's going on like well florida has
the lowest of infection right in the
country and it has the losses rules
yeah so what so i don't understand how
none of the the reality of things isn't
permeating
some of the smartest people i know yeah
aren't asking questions that's what was
blowing my mind yeah like one of my
neighbors like the smartest dude i know
i'm like dude you don't think this like
you you're the one who always tells me
to ask questions and i forget and now
you're like you're not asking any ques
like
you and you come back to la and it's
like there's a lot more mandates and
stuff here in strictness even though i i
feel like it's getting a little looser
though um
but then you go you still get hostility
from people who if you ask questions
about it yeah
why is there something inside of some
people they're just afraid to question
or do you think that they
just
i don't know some things for me to if i
saw more people dying around me you know
and i'm not saying people haven't died
but i don't know one person that's died
you know well people did die but
people are dying in the vaccine too
and we're not you know there's there's
19 000 people
whose death has been reported
after vaccination now during the um in
when we had the vaccine the flu vaccine
46 people died and they pulled the
vaccine well now 19 000 and what's
what hhs says
is that that system is only capturing
one percent of the vaccine injuries
it could be much much higher than that
and you're seeing a lot of people who
are dropping dead of sudden death who
are young people who should not be dying
you read about it every day yesterday
the
editorial page editor of the washington
post you know died suddenly
and you're seeing that you know
sports figures who have dropped out on
the field
you're seeing those and those guys are
not being reported as vaccine injuries
oh you know um but why wouldn't like
places that are why wouldn't they be
reported as vaccinations and like why
wouldn't we get that information who's
going to report it
the doctors you know first of all it
takes a half hour to do the report
doctors don't want to do it and the
doctors are telling themselves that's
not a vaccine injury that guy just had a
heart attack you know they don't want to
admit to themselves that it's a vaccine
particularly if they gave the vaccine to
the guy they don't want to say it was an
intervention that killed him
that's the problem with the voluntary
system you need a system that is a
machine counting system one that which
you can easily do
hhs actually developed one they look at
all the they know who got it which
vaccine
down to the batch number
and then you do a cluster analysis and
saying are those guys more likely to die
are they more likely to get diabetes
rheumatoid arthritis ms than the people
who weren't you can look at that and you
can do it very quickly but none of that
is being done all of that kind of
research gets blocked
i just blows my mind that that there's
no liability for these for the companies
making things because i just feel we've
had such a
it's it's become obvious for me anyway
and it's just me that
drug companies don't care about people
you know like all the people that died
of drug overdoses and oxycode all those
it's just like it it just seems real
obvious so i don't know why
there's just such an immediate truck
like
just a a it was just this immediate
almost like forced clo everything was
just closing and it just seemed like a
everyone was just going to trust
suddenly drug companies that's the part
that really i guess is always just made
me uncomfortable you know i mean i never
trusted anybody i mean these are the
same companies that gave us the opioid
epidemic that's what killed 56 000 kids
a year and more
more kids every year than died in the
entire vietnam war over 20 years
and every year we know they did it
deliberately the four big vaccine
companies in this country it's an oafy
merc pfizer and galaxo have paid 35
billion dollars over the last 10 years
in criminal penalties and
damages for the flooding regulators for
lying to doctors for killing hundreds of
thousands of american violence which was
merge drug it knew it was going to cause
heart attacks and kill people but i
thought they can't be sued for oh they
can be sued for they can't be sued for
vaccinations
but even in the place where they can get
sued
their criminal culture is part of who
they are and even though when they know
they're going to get caught they're
going to get caught they still do it so
what happens to that same company
when he knows there's no way he'll ever
get caught because there's no discovery
there's no depositions there's no
document searches and even if you find
out
that he
killed you
you can't sue him
right
you think fauci is an evil do you think
it's evil that's in him i mean i mean
are you saying that with this book that
he's just an evil guy
or do you think he's compromised would
anybody have been him it's just a power
and he's just a he's just the man in the
position is there darker forces at work
listen
we all as you know
think of ourselves as we measure
ourselves by our intention rather than
by her by behavior so i don't know
whether
he um i don't know how he views himself
and i i
know
that he must believe that it's okay
to impose collateral damage on people in
order maybe he's convincing himself
there's a larger cause
but you know i've documented again and
again and again how he's with the azt
during the aids epidemic which he knew
was poisoning people killed 330 000
people and he knew it was doing that and
that it was worthless and he let it
happen
um hannah aaron who wrote a lot about
the third reich and she was a you know
philosopher and writer and holocaust
survivor
she talked about death killers during
the third reich there were people who
worked in the
you know there were guards and death
camps that were actually killing people
escorting him into gas chambers
she said the worst of the people
were the people who killed from their
desks the people who made these big
decisions that involved tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people and assigned it and then you know
signed off on it and then went home and
kissed the wife and pet the dog and
hugged their children and thought very
very highly of themselves and i think
that's what i think um you know dr fauci
is i think he's a death skiller
and do you think and how what what role
does bill gates play in it so much i
know you mentioned him a lot in the book
gates um called falci to his home
in 2000 and summons them to his 187
million dollar mansion on the banks laid
washington up in seattle
and he brought him into the den and he
said i want to propose a partnership
with you damn it's like a damn uh
what's that movie
dude the mur uh with the italian guys
you know i'm talking about godfathers oh
yeah oh god
so he so you believe that they're just
in cahoots
well i know they are and what is it just
business that they're doing do they just
think it's just business in fact do you
think that they thinking like michael's
sherman or something like michael
spector
asked
um tony fauci
what his favorite line from his favorite
movie was and he said it's the godfather
and my favorite line is it's just
business
and i think
that you know he really does look at
this as a um
as a
you know he's promoting pharmaceutical
products he does not do basic science
anymore he doesn't do the job that he's
being hired to do he develops
pharmaceutical products and he's turned
his agency into an incubator for the
pharmaceutical company he creates the
products there he sells them he
he shares patents with the big drug
companies with the universities and then
he gets them through the regulatory
process and promotes them
and you know during
we've gone
during his 50-year period there we've
gone from being the healthiest
population in the world to the sickest
we are literally
of the top 79 countries in the world are
you serious
we have the worst health
we use three times the pharmaceutical
drugs of any other nation
we pay the highest prices and we have
the worst health outcomes of the 79
top countries in the world we are the
worst and he's been in charge the whole
time yes and is he the one who writes
the checks for research is it his
company yeah he gives away a 7.6 billion
dollars a year and him personally he
gets the right that you choose who gets
it he chooses who gets it there's not a
board that does it no well
he chooses he runs that agency with a a
tight end
what he does is he'll develop these
drugs within his labs
and they form them out to you know what
they'll do is
in his lab he has thousands of vials of
coronavirus of dengue virus hanki virus
a flu of you know all of the different
polio whatever
and
they'll take different combination of
molecules and they drip them into that
lab culture and see if it kills the
virus
if it kills the virus
and they have an antiviral so now they
have to say does it kill the rat
because if it kills the virus but it
doesn't kill the rat yeah they have a
medicine
then he farms it out to the university
and he gives them money so the
university will
do animal studies and they'll do phase
one studies which is 100 people
basically
he will give that university the dean of
that department who is called the
principal investigator
15 to 20 000 dollars per recruit that
dean is a doctor he's recruiting
patients
to test this drug
he's getting let's say 20 000 per
patient that he recruits to participate
in that for that trial the university
skims off 50 to 75 percent of that money
keeps it so now the university is now
partnering with faculty
well that's the face phase two studies
in phase three where they're bringing in
ten or twenty thousand people they now
bring in the drug company and the drug
company gets most of the patent tony
felt she could keep some for himself for
his agency
or his individuals right the university
gets keep on the university bi gets to
keep it
and then fauci ushers it through the
regulatory process so here's the punch
line between 2009 and 2016
there were
240 new drugs that word that were
approved by fda that came through tony
fauci's shop oh he is the biggest
pharmaceutical incubator in the world
he's a cbs
he's not doing what he's supposed to do
which was trying to figure out where's
the autism epidemic coming from why do
we now have diabetes i remember you
talking about this last time we were
together we got one question that came
in about that actually from a young man
and thank you for your time robert
what's up mr kennedy
i have a question for you i have a
four-year-old
autistic son
uh i know you've done a little research
uh with vaccines and uh
how it all ties in together
maybe you could dive into that some and
also
with the technology growing
uh rapidly do you think there's a chance
for uh some normalcy
for my boy moving forward in his life
i appreciate your time big fan theo gang
gang hey baby
i guess you kind of answered some of
that
yeah where is he going from he looked
like it was a look like oklahoma or
something huh
like an airplane or something but yeah
he might have been who knows man
probably trying to get off the planet i
don't blame him as scary down here well
i mean
here's what happened in my generation
one in uh 10 000 between 1 and 2 500
there's a couple different studies that
look at the prevalence of autism
oh yeah yeah and people are 67 so
my generation between 1 and 25 100 and 1
and 10 000 people have have autism
even today
my age i've never seen anybody with
full-blown autism my age oh i know a lot
of people
you know people who are
who are like the quirky uncle or the
person whose asperges or can't look you
in the eye yeah party also i'm talking
about full-blown autism people men who
are six seven-year-old in diapers
wearing a football helmet head-banging
non-verbal
non-toilet trained uh alabama fans
basically is what you're saying honestly
but no i know what you're saying sorry
you know stimming toe walking you know
i've never seen somebody like that and i
have been around intellectual
disabilities my whole life my family
started special olympics best bodies etc
never seen anybody my age with it in my
my kids age group is one in every 22
boys according to cdc one in every 34
kids
oh tony fauci's uh
is to figure out why that's happening it
it when the epa was told congress said
the epa
tell us what year the autism epidemic
began the epa scientists came back and
they said in 1989 it's a red line
and so tony fauci's got a pretty easy
job he has to figure out a an exposure a
chemical exposure or some other exposure
it happened beginning in 1989 that
affected every demographic group
at from cubans and key biscayne to
inuit home or alaska everybody in
between
and that um
you know that affected boys at a four to
one ratio to girls there has to be a
chemical that does that so or some other
exposure now there's a scientist called
phil landrigan
he narrowed it down to 11 things
one on
glyphosate which is roundup
oh yeah i'm a roundup so you need
something that suddenly exploded around
1989 yeah
um it could be pfoas
which are flame retardants which became
ubiquitous around that same time like it
could be cell phones
it could be
ultrasound it could be neonicotinoid
pesticides it could be corn syrup
but there's a limited number of things
it can be right right and it's an easy
thing to do the science to figure out
which one it is and we haven't done it
and donny valjey hasn't done it but all
of these neurodevelopmental autoimmune
and um
and allergic diseases that suddenly
exploded in 1989
are business all of them are also listed
as side effects of vaccine on the
manufacturer's insert of the 72 vaccine
we went
i was again i got three vaccines my kids
got 72 vaccines
and it changed in 89
vaccines have to be on that list for a
whole lot and there's a lot of science
that says that's what's causing it
including
a 1999 cdc study called the first
stratton study that they never released
we got a hold of it they looked at the
biggest database in the country the
vaccine safety data link
they looked at kids who got the
hepatitis b vaccine during the first 30
days and compared it to kids who did not
get it or got it after 30 days and
here's what they found
the kids who got it had an 1135
percent greater chance of getting on
autism
autism diagnosis than kids who did not
and that is pretty strong evidence
what do you think is a solution then to
kind of where we're at now you feel like
anthony fauci shouldn't be in his space
no he should he should be imprisoned
but
the solution is really with all of us we
need to resist
we need you know nobody ever complied
their way out of totalitarian rule
we've seen our bill of rights
obliterated we're seeing a level of
totalitarianism that is unprecedented in
you know what but it's not just america
it's across all the liberal democracies
in the world
and all the powers these governments
have accumulated over the last to tell
you to not do your business to not go to
church to stay in your house to put on a
mass do what you're told
there's no government in history
that has ever relinquished power once it
got it
without a demand
we need to start demanding that our
government
that we're not going to comply anymore
and all of us have to
what i tell people is you need to do
three civil disobediences a day and that
could be just talking to your neighbor
and educating them it could be telling
somebody in your local store who has a
don't come in if you don't have a math
sign
i'm not going to shop here anymore and
um it could be uh you know
it could be buying my book and giving it
to somebody who doesn't and i don't get
any money off that book it all goes to
children's health defense really
yeah oh wow man that's awesome yeah it
all goes to fund our litigation and um
so uh but you know people need to start
resisting we need to start reclaiming
our rights it was a we need to start
loving
our freedom more than we
fear a germ
and there was a whole um generation of
americans who lived in 1776
who said there's worse things than dying
and living without these liberties is
worse than death yeah and thanks to them
we have the bill of rights they put
their livelihood their property and
their lives on the line so that we could
have these rights and in 20 months we've
given them away we need to get them back
oh look man you you know you're a friend
and i've long appreciated your uh you
know you're taking care of the
environment and looking out for the
environment outside of us and and now
inside of our bodies man i know it's
important to you and and uh i enjoyed
the book man the real anthony fauci uh
about robert kennedy jr you guys check
it out um it's
it's
i mean it's a it's a interesting read
man thank you so much for coming on
thank you
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
but when i reach that ground i'll share
this piece of mind i found i can feel it
in my bones
but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
hands
[Music]
now